thank you
[Music]
this is star talk I'm Neil deGrasse
Tyson your personal astrophysicist and
today I we haven't figured out a title
for this uh Chuck you want to call it
Mafia Malcolm Mafia Malcolm we're
sticking with that oh my God how catchy
is that I said kid I some advertising
companies should be recruiting me right
now
Chuck Nice my co-host Chuck always good
to have you here always a pleasure so
the Malcolm of which you speak is I I
gotta call him a special guest because
this guy is out and about I'm afraid to
put them on my show because that means
he's not otherwise writing his next book
like I'm in in the way of this man's
productive career in progress Malcolm
Gladwell welcome back to StarTalk thank
you yeah we had we had you on stage live
it might have been five or six minutes
back when those things happened yeah
yeah
but you were and just one quick
correction Neil Malcolm is so prolific
he's actually writing a book right now
while we're talking
Malcolm is in the midst of composing his
next work
because like I'm very serious I don't
like taking time away from people that
they could be doing some productive uh
but a whole string of best sellers blink
uh forgive me I haven't read all of them
but I read many of them and blank
outliers the Tipping Point there's some
very famous books in here David and
Goliath checking the list here what the
dogs saw
um why don't we just start with the
stuff Malcolm hasn't written and then
back into whatever right it might take a
less time you have one of my favorite
podcasts online right now revisionist
history and now in its sixth season
and this is where you sort of dissect a
commonly held truth and figure out well
maybe it's not as true as people think
it's a brilliant format and and you're
going strong and you've got a new book
the bomber Mafia okay there's your now I
see your connections the bomber Mafia a
dream a Temptation and the longest night
in the second world war yeah man we'll
get into that in a bit uh so uh let me
ask you Malcolm you you last time you
were on we discussed sort of sociology
and The Human Condition about which
you've written uh quite a bit and what
I've found is that you instead of just
teaching people textbook style instead
of only telling stories you've you've
found a way to stitch together
first person narrative or a narrative
that directly relates to another human
being who we can think about their
existence and the science related to it
and that's an art the way you've that
that's an art so I would you suggest
that if scientists want to communicate
they should adopt your methods here
hmm all right I'm gonna handle this one
for you Malcolm yes okay
okay
you know I would only say that
the if you're a scientist I mean you
were saying earlier jokingly that you
didn't
you you were worried that if you
interviewed me I wouldn't have time to
write I don't want my scientists
spending all their time writing popular
books I want them doing
science right I mean I want people to
specialize in what they do best we're
not
selecting out
our astrophysicists and our chemists and
our biologists for their ability to
explain their ideas to the
public we're selecting them for their
ability to push the boundaries of
Science and it may well be that the
thing that makes them good at pushing
the boundaries of science makes them bad
at expanding their ideas to the general
public I'm fine with that trade-off you
know the reason God invented journalists
is that we can come along and do that
job for them
um I was wondering where a journalists
came from
to be intermediary between the genius
and the public right that's what that's
what we're doing you know I'm not I'm
not pushing the boundaries of science
I'm just telling stories and standing
between uh the public and Science and
that's that's what we that's what we're
supposed to do yeah but you have to
boost your science literacy so that you
don't fumble over the the content right
interesting
yeah although you know
um what I've discovered is that first of
all I steer clear of those areas where I
don't feel you'll find that I you know I
I don't write about the the most
complicated corners of medicine are
biology I stick pretty much to those
areas of science that I find personally
accessible
so I do think it's You Know It's Tricky
not everything can be explained to a
general public you know it's like the
the
remember when Stephen Hawking's a short
history of time was a
bestseller and there was a kind of an
open joke about whether anyone who was
buying it was reading it because like
that is not a you know the idea that you
know you some a standard normally
educated human being could read that
book and make sense of it is a little
bit of a stretch I I didn't have a
prayer I got like 10 pages in I was like
you know what this is just
so far above my pay grade that night so
you know there's uh there are real
limits to whether
um just certain parts whether certain
parts of science can be made accessible
not sure they should be yeah you're
you're deep in the publishing world was
it true or is it just a story I heard
that the Publishers wanted to actually
find out if people were reading A Brief
History of Time by Stephen Hawking so
for in some set of books they put in
like a coupon and said mail this in and
get a hundred dollars and like nobody
mailed it in because they never got that
far in the book no yeah no it's like
that was there's a famous story about
um the guy who in uh Ron Popeil remember
him the pitch man on TV yeah fisherman
his dad invented the Pocket Fisherman oh
and when his father who was his name was
SJ SJ was once asked was what someone
once said to him the Pocket Fisherman
you know it doesn't work and SJ said
very wisely it's not for using it's
forgiving
that's an excellent quote
I feel like the Stephen Hawking book was
for was forgiving not for reading so can
I ask you this then as a person who is a
you know almost I mean you know on the
level of a sociologist because of so
much that you have written about and
studied on human uh kind and Human
Condition do you think that as a society
we are pulling away from scientific
literacy and if so why would that be
well I wonder about this so this this
this question comes up a lot about is
there something distinctive about the
moment we're living in and our and
popular attitudes towards expertise of
one kind to another and I would say
Malcolm your books they bring people
into the science and they show how the
science manifest so so I think you are a
force of good in in this in this on this
landscape but go on but I I was gonna
say I think the people who say that
we're living in a uniquely
anti-scientific moment have a short
memory so let me give you two stories
from my mom my mom grows up in Jamaica
and gets a scholarship to a boarding
school in the 1930s and she's reading
the Encyclopedia Britannica and she
learns to her reading some section on I
don't know what the section was on race
or something she learns to her horror
that the Encyclopedia Britannica
considers black people to be genetically
inferior to white people right so this
is
1930 whatever it is seven in Jamaica
then she tries to marry my father who is
white and discovers to her [ __ ] that a
good majority of people think that it is
not just kind of casually a bad idea for
white people to marry black people but
like something that is you know a
profound problem for the future of
civilization right because they believe
that the mixing of the races represents
those are two pretty firmly held views
of that period and Eugenics was flying
high at the time and Eugene is flying
high like first of all that's 70 years
ago not that long ago and those are two
crazy Notions that were held by among
other things the Encyclopedia Britannica
right so are we have we made progress I
kind of think so like no one's saying
stuff that crazy today at least not on
that level of this it's slightly
pretended today does not have those kind
of Whoppers in it wait wait wait but
just to be fair to to Chuck's question
um there were scientists saying that at
the time so the fact that the
Encyclopedia Britannica Echoes this is
not being anti-science they're just oh
promulgated that's just promulgated
these anthropologists of the day that's
different all right all right so the
this brings this opens up some
categories here because
uh this concept of skin color and race
as as we know in the history of this
country is quite uh colorful as to put
it mildly and that is a very deep deeply
um endemic
feature of society as so many other
topics are that you have addressed in
your books so do you have a certain
um a priority order which you say I want
to do this topic because it's the most
inflammatory or because you have the
best stories to tell and and that then
shapes your books
I think it starts from what question is
Meaningful to me
um not sort of globally meaningful but
meaningful at the moment so for example
since we're on the subject of race which
is Meaningful for me for personal
reasons you know because I come from a
mixed race background because I find
that issue in this current season of
revisionist History I have a whole thing
about hbcus and
why don't we it's all about historically
black colleges and universities yeah and
about the particular role they play in
American Education that's largely
unrecognized and it was super
interesting to me both because
um
you know for personal reasons that's
near and dear to my heart but also I'm
I've always been interested in kind of
um managing or learning to understand
the relationship between
um the kind of the the dominant
community in the United States and
minorities
because I am announced I'm a I'm a
Canadian I'm a half Jamaican I'm I'm all
these Outsider things that question of
how does the dominant group interact
with people who aren't dominant it's
just it's just interesting to me I mean
it's just like it's at the core of what
I think about when I when I think about
the world and when I think about my
mother's Evolution for a moment so she
grows up in a world where uh any
Jamaican would or any West Indian Wood
where people in positions of authority
are as likely to be almost more likely
to be black as white so she grew up in a
world where the doctors were black where
the teachers were black where the
politicians were black where the lawyers
were black and so it never occurred to
her that
these were opportunities that weren't
open to black people the black people
couldn't do those jobs and then she
comes to North America and suddenly
she doesn't see any black doctors or
black lawyers or black politicians at
least in the 70s and that transition is
super interesting right to and I was you
know I'm a kid and I'm observing this
I'm observing my mother go through this
transition
um and trying and struggling with it I
mean we lived in a town where there were
two black people my mom and actually
three and these twin adopted girls of
the local Lutheran Minister the Goosey
twins that's it great people a town of
seven thousand people right then my
mother has to navigate that fact all of
a sudden she's the only person who looks
like her it's weird and it's also
strange for the other people who've
never seen a well-spoken well-educated
you know uh black person before can I
touch your hair yeah I'm sure oh no it
wasn't you know what it was Neil I
wonder whether you've ever gotten this
when my mom was in England going to
school in the 50s what she got was
people wanting to touch her skin to see
whether it quote it would come off
yeah okay that was the yeah so there's a
whole I I would just tell them that it's
pink
it does come up but uh quite frankly you
need a special solution so and I can't
share that with you unfortunately yeah
but I will say this this is not as not
even as a pushback but just as an
addendum it may be an eight
universally
but it's like a 12 for black people in
America that's the only difference yeah
you know that's the difference is that
there's a it's an extra it goes extra
it's extra in America and like you said
about your mom you know here she is
seeing a society where black people do
hold Authority in positions of authority
I mean that was anathema in in America
and subsequently North America and you
know it's in my childhood growing up I
had a pediatrician and uh my mother's
doctor were black this this is part of
my every American child School child
should be required to spend at least one
year of their life attending a school in
Atlanta
why because that's the American city
where they are most likely to see black
people in positions of authority lots of
them right a really good up and down the
Spectrum that's right up and down the
Spectrum right you go to a restaurant in
Atlanta you will see you know 50 of the
seats in the restaurant will be occupied
by black people chances are you go to
the doctor chances are your doctor will
be a black person you need to be exposed
people should be exposed to that to
understand that their little world is
not representative of the world out
there you know I think internal years
abroad would be a really good idea for
America right I like the internal years
yeah no you don't think about Africa to
see black people go to Atlanta
no I I said I was just in just in
Atlanta I love Atlanta for that very
reason I just think later like you know
it's just it's a different place same
thing with Washington DC by the way same
very similar kind of Worlds where you
just get a that's a to me a much more
realistic except in Congress but
anywhere else you'll be fine yeah well
we're accepting Congress from I'm
talking about Washington DC outside
outside of government okay we're gonna
take a quick break when we come back
more of our exclusive interview with
Malcolm Gladwell and all that makes his
brain tick on Star Talk
we're back start talk I got Malcolm
Gladwell in the house and Chuck Nice my
co-host here Chuck you're tweeting Chuck
Nice comic still well thank you sir yes
and the more you say it the more I have
to keep that handle okay
not that I care I love that you say it
uh and Malcolm tell me your social media
handles
do I know them hold on I think I'm at
Gladwell and Twitter I'm really bad on
social media I'm you know I'm I'm an old
dude oh you want people to like read
your books
I I
yeah I think it's that I think it's that
Global that's it that's it exactly I'm
the only Global on Twitter as far as I
can tell Gladwell okay all right cool
all right so let's get back into this
um we left off uh with the
recommendation that everyone take a a a
a staycation in the United States and
just visit Atlanta
they got to go to school in Atlanta you
got to live in Atlanta you can't just
visit you need to stay there you need to
stay there for a while move around if
you're you know I was I was on this trip
when I was Atlanta I was going for a run
and I just to be clear you're an avid
Runner correct I am an avid yeah and I'm
running around and this guy starts right
next to you and we start chatting and
he's white guy and I said know what do
you do he goes I'm a a uh he's at my
medical resident it's like oh where'd
you go to med school he goes Morehouse
and I said wait a second how many white
people go to go to university of did you
go to Morehouse medical school he goes
well I was a small number but I I love
that fact and he wanted he got
interested in medicine because he went
to Africa spent 10 years in Nigeria and
Kenya came back and said uh I need you
know I'd like to become a doctor to help
people but it seemed at that point after
10 years in Africa it was natural for
him
to want to go to a place like Morehouse
medical school right he was comfortable
around people who didn't look like him
and that just tells me that that that's
the advantage of people who live a
Cosmopolitan life who get out of their
own little worlds that they think they
don't think twice about it and Malcolm
there's got to be a lot of unmind
stories about going out fish out of
water or really the in water is just a
different different water right I mean I
remembered my at my elementary school
and I don't want this to be about me
here because we don't have much you know
how often do we have Malcolm Gladwell in
the house but in elementary school by
whatever measures of exams that were
administered I was not put in the
special the the the the advanced class
the advanced class got to take a foreign
language they got special teachers that
all this was going on and and I knew I
wanted to do that but the system
prevented it I was one of three black
people in my elementary school all right
in middle school I go to Lexington
Massachusetts because my father has an
appointment up at Harvard a one-year
fellowship and so I'm living in
Lexington Massachusetts and I go to the
Regional Middle School there are three
black people in that school once again I
get the highest grades in the school in
four semesters and I graduate getting
accolades and accolades and awards and I
got pins and and and and and I'm
thinking myself okay
um I don't know what's going on here
okay why in one place they say I'm not
deserving in another place I'm at the
top of the class but I was not thinking
and I should have you know this is good
for the white people to see this
right right it's so because
blackhead one of three black children in
this middle school and uh Untouchable by
it plus I was I was on all the sports so
I could like outrun them and out and so
I think maybe every every white kid who
who's been told like from the
Encyclopedia Britannica and its
derivatives over the decades that they
somehow represent some platform of
superiority you need stories like this
perhaps they need to get their clock
cleaned by right
Middle School however you know the uh
the other consideration is that uh up in
Massachusetts you were going to school
with slow Dumb white people
all right there's another one I want to
like rub it in but but you know I grew
up my time up until then was in the
Bronx right and so there's a basketball
court and so I'm there and I go to take
a pickup game of basketball and someone
is ready to shoot and I jumped to block
the shot and I end up blocking his shot
with my elbow because I jumped 18 inches
higher than was necessary
wait that's funny right could you expect
to block it with your hand but I kept
rising and the boy he didn't jump higher
with me and my elbow blocked the shot
and I said wait where am I
Neil wait I have a question for you Neil
um how tall are you I'm uh six two okay
I was reading this this is a sobering
note in this discussion I was reading
just the other day this big discussion
of school suspensions for some reason
for long reasons which I can get into or
not I've become really fascinated by
Chill by school suspensions and as you
know the data says that
uh
black kids particularly black males are
way more likely to be suspended for the
same offense than their white
equivalents right but there is a Nuance
to this that broke my heart which is
when you look at all of the variables
that most predict being suspended being
black is one bling a black male is two
being a tall black male is the
overwhelming predictor there is
something about so I can equalize
everything and if you're if you're tall
and black and male you are getting
singled out for punishment in a way that
outstrips every other conceivable yeah
well it's hard to miss you
you're tall and black but it's it's
triggering something yeah and like and
and the reason is so this is important
for a million different reasons but this
is the kind of thing that in a million
years the teachers or principals making
those decisions would never think they
might think am I singling out a kid
because he's black or am I singling out
of kid because he's a black boy they
would never think they were singling out
someone unfairly because they were tall
so I I was I was typically the second
tallest kid in my class
um and so but I wasn't oddly tall and
but I had very gentle demeanor so so I I
was never at risk of sort of a truant
conduct uh I was I I never got into
fights other people began to fight I
never got into fights were you also a
good student
well the pressure between Me by good bro
I'm saying average grades I had very
average grades for most of my life well
when you're black the expectations are
lower so you are a great students you
were a really good student
I'm sorry I had to do that that's a joke
people that's a joke okay so Malcolm
let's let's talk about your your
current book it has many more words in
the title than any of your other books a
lot of words so please please defend
yourself there
foreign
it has an unwieldy subtitle uh a dream
of Temptation in the longest night of
the second world war
um it is
uh it's and it's a different book than
any I've ever written it's not a it's
not a cut it doesn't go in a million
directions it's not a it's a Str it's a
it's a it's a not a pure history book
but very close to it it's a story about
this weird little bit of
history in the second world war which
was a group of Pilots down in Alabama
who thought they had solved one of the
uh most difficult physics problem
problems in Modern War which is how to
drop a plane a bomb from a plane with uh
with a high degree of accuracy which if
you think about it is that's an insanely
hard problem right you've got you're six
miles up you're going 250 miles an hour
you're dropping a large heavy object
through uh constantly changing air
pressure weather blown by blown by winds
uh different temperatures to us to a
small Target on the ground that might be
obscured by clouds I mean it's insanely
difficult right and most people don't
know I'd say correctly if I'm wrong
about Malcolm because surely you
researched this was it something like
eighty percent of bombs dropped in the
second world war missed their target oh
yeah I'm not just by a little bit by an
enormous amount right the British the
British do a study early in the war
called the hull report and they think
they're doing a really good job of
hitting German targets and they
discovered they're like off by as much
as seven miles that's how bad it is
gentlemen I'm sorry to report we're
actually bombing ourselves that's right
and you want to be high enough so that
anti-aircraft can't get you so this
they're competing forces on your
accuracy
so they these guys think they've solved
this problem and they then go to the
next stage and say if we've solved this
problem we can solve the problem of War
right because we we want we can wage war
in a way that doesn't result in hundreds
of thousands of Civilian casualties we
can bring a city to its knees without
destroying it we can take on our enemy
without having to use armies and
infantry and navy and we can just use
bombers that just
precisely take out the thing we want to
take out the the aqueducts the power
plant the bridges and they're they'll
they'll surrender right
um and this incredible dream which is
hatched in Montgomery of Alabama by the
way the only incredible dream hatch
there ever happened a till wait wait
wait wait until the Montgomery Bus
Boycott
1965. there you go uh is it 65 no 55. in
the 50s definitely anyway
um they hatched his dream and they take
it into the second world war and they
they ascend the ranks of the Air Force
in the second world war with this
incredibly ambitious disruptive idea
that the only thing that matters is the
bomber because the bomber can drop bombs
with perfect accuracy wherever they want
and they run into the reality of warfare
and
um this dream and its confrontation with
reality ends in spectacular fashion over
the skies of Tokyo in 1945. my book is
about that Journey from the hatching of
the dream in Montgomery in in the
mid-30s to its kind of cataclysmic
failure
um in in over Japan in the summer of
1945. all right what's the temptation
but you don't mean the firebombing of
Tokyo do you no well the fire lobbying
is what results from the failure of
their dream so the Temptation is the
dream is we can clean up Modern Warfare
and use these perfectly aimed bombs the
Temptation is when that strategy doesn't
work it's just to say you know eff it
let's just let's just firebomb
everything down and burn everything down
and my dreamers won't take up the
temptation but somebody else does that's
the darkest chapter of the second world
war right chocolate interrupted you what
are you saying no he answered my
question I said if that if that's the
dream what is the temptation but now I'm
intrigued to know who is this Darth
Vader figure who comes in in and creates
the darkness chapter in the second world
war which God I mean that's such a
bloody war how I mean to say that this
person is the author of the darkest
chapter wow wow chapter of The Darkest
War yes the darkest chapter of The
Darkest War who is this Darth vader-like
creature
a man named General Curtis LeMay one of
the most infamous or famous depending on
your perspective uh military aviators of
the 20th century
um who uh who's just an extraordinary
character I mean the most kind of brutal
ruthless unsentimental
brilliant
and you know he goes on from there of
course if you remember he's he was I
lost count I think at nine or ten the
number of Hollywood movies that had
Curtis LeMay a villain based on Curtis
LeMay in there I mean Dr strangelop
there's a Curtis LeMay figuring doctor
strangely so he's influenced a a a a a a
what do you call a character type A yes
he is he's become a truck yeah yes he
stands for the crazy cold Warriors the
nuclear finger on the Button he's the
guy so Lemay is the guy who Napalm is is
invented in the second world war not
Vietnam for the express purposes of
burning down Japanese cities because
they were made of wood and they were
highly flammable and the first one a lot
of walls or paper and paper yes exactly
and the the first person to use Napalm
to its fullest extent was this man
Curtis LeMay the first person with the
kind of
gumption
to say uh I'm gonna give up on all
traditional forms of warfare and I'm
just going to drop so many fire bombs on
these flammable cities that I will
literally burn my enemy out and that's
what he does and he kills in the summer
of 45 he fire bombs he burns to the
ground 66 Japanese cities and maybe
kills close to a million civilians I
mean it's
it's an astonishing the if you list the
middle the people in the 20th century
you were responsible for the most
civilian deaths uh Mal's one sounds two
Hitler's three Paul Potts four and
Curtis LeMay is five and American is
number five
well I'm certainly adding him to my list
of people I'd like to have at a cocktail
party that's right
uh just one thing I'll add just to end
the segment on a completely down note
Napalm at least of the variety they used
in Vietnam maybe the early versions
weren't quite this potent
um the Napalm doesn't just simply burn
it burns at an extremely high
temperature like thousands of degrees
and so what happens is where Napalm is
dropped it sucks all of the oxygen out
of that region so even if you were not
burned by the oxygen you burned by the
flames and the temperatures you
suffocated from the absence of oxygen
and in in firebombing tactics in Tokyo I
don't know if you've ever done this this
is I've done this I I used to do it when
I still put as many candles in a
birthday cake as my age which of course
I've stopped but if you put candles
around the rim of a cake
all right you know get at least 10 but
ideally like 20 just do that and then
ignite them and just watch what happens
all candles Point directly radially into
the center of the cake
are you serious because what you've
heated the air not only outside the cake
but inside the middle of the cake but
there's more heat in the inside the cake
than outside right because they're all
sort of focused there and so if you heat
the air there that air rises other air
comes in from outside to replace it
pushing the candle Flames inward so
while they were firebombing these cities
you don't have to ignite every square
inch you just have to make a circle
and then all the the air will come in
and push the flames and completely
incinerate everything in the center of
the circle is that what they call a
firestorm or a conflagration it is that
well those are elements of it yes but
what I'm describing is you're using the
forces of of physics and chemistry to
reduce how many actual bombs you would
have to drop and these are people like
think this stuff up
um I'm very grateful that you didn't use
your formidable gifts for ill
if you if you decide to become a bad guy
[Laughter]
again just to end it on a completely
down note
um I have more than once and it's never
received well I don't know why Malcolm
maybe you you have the answer to this
before we go to our third segment but
people talk about sort of violence in
the cities or violence during Wars or
terrorist attacks and it doesn't appear
to be bandwidth to hear the following
fact that from 1939 to 1945 so that the
the duration of the second World War One
thousand people
per hour were killed in the name of that
war oh my God that's terrible per hour
and there is nothing today where people
are dying at that rate and so much lower
things get people's you know
astonishment and I'm just thinking you
know people alive today were alive at a
time where that went every hour from
1939 to 1945. and and so yes the world
used to be worse than it is today I'm
just you know put that out there God we
gotta take a quick break when we come
back
um we'll try to land This Plane it might
be hard because Malcolm isn't is a is a
fount of
enlightened insight into you're the one
who just told the birthday cake story
why you're telling everybody that's
supplemental to your tour you just
taught a generation of listeners how to
like create a firestorm
I'm just very observant where if I see
stuff that's all and so you could you
could you could actually put candles
adjacent to those candles Inward and
they would each light their way into the
center I mean you could do that
experiment anyhow we're gonna take a
break when we come back more with the
one and only Malcolm Gladwell on start
talk
we're back Star Talk co-host check nice
check it baby hey all right and Malcolm
Gladwell uh and Malcolm I feel like I
know you even though we've only met a
couple of times only because your books
are so accessible it's like you're a
friend of mine sitting next to me and
that's a talent that you've honed ever
since your days at the New Yorker
um and I just want to say dangerous
Talent
that's a very dangerous Talent man only
in the hands of the wrong person okay
right that's the theme that's the theme
of this conversation that's right that's
right if we all turn evil so in revision
is history like I said it's one of my
favorite podcasts out there
um you open your season with a
discussion of self-driving cars and you
and this is a little weird and I don't
know if you know do you need to be
checked out on this where you try to get
a self-driving car to hit somebody what
did you try what tell me what happened
first of all let me just say Bravo yeah
well
for some reason I stumbled across this
paper
by a guy who said he was like a an urban
planner and he writes This brilliant
paper where he says now wait a minute if
all the cars on the road are
self-driving then that changes the
psychological dynamic between cars and
pedestrians the reason you don't jaywalk
now or you jaywalk we do jaywalk but we
jaywalk pretty sparingly right the
reason everyone doesn't jaywalk all the
time is that we're really worried that
someone who's driving a car is either
crazy and will hit us or distracted and
we'll hit us we know we don't jailbreak
all the time because we know that the
human drivers of cars are imperfect
self-driving cars autonomous vehicles
are they're not absolutely perfect but
they're really close right so this guy
says well if the fear of an imperfect
driver is removed what do you do if
you're a pedestrian you jaywalk all the
time
you could walk out into the middle of a
freeway
at 100 and they will all stop they will
all stop so I thought this was such a
hilarious
observation so you need to program in
some psychopathy you need some
psychopathy programmed into that car you
guys what is it what is it you guys are
absolutely right wait you've jumped
ahead of me oh I'm sorry I'm sorry wait
we're getting there yes yes yes yes yes
yes so right now so
I go to uh Phoenix where waymo operates
Google's waymo and that is the only
place in the country where you can hail
like an Uber you can hail a self-driving
car it'll come pick you up and drive
around so we got ourselves a waymo and
we drove around dinner for a while and
it was it is clear the draw the driver
the the the the the algorithm the AI
That's driving way Mouse is the nicest
kindest most patient most long-suffering
driver in the history of drivers this is
a driver who never gets angry who will
never flip you the bird who will never
lean on the horn who will never speed up
when he should be slowing down it's a
perfect driver so then I said oh oh they
actually slow down when they're
approaching a yellow transition between
a green and a red never run they'll
never do anything they're perfect so I
said oh this this means that I can do
whatever I want so I got out of the car
we're gonna we're in a parking lot of a
Alamo Drafthouse in Chandler Arizona and
I got out and I started to mess with the
waymo and I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
give it away but I was like running next
to the waymo and I was trying to see
whether if I behave like an idiot
what would the waymo do right now I know
what I what a driver would do a human
driver if I did hit me
what about what would happen if you know
um so it was this great reminder first
of all that the people who come up with
new technologies don't always think
through all of the implications
no one thought when it came up with the
idea for autonomous vehicles that what
they were really doing was liberating
pedestrians to do whatever the hell they
want is that wasn't on the table that
was not on their mind they were like not
fair and I realized you know if you if
you make every car in Manhattan
self-driving you realize that you'll no
car will be able to make it down the
street right right that's true yeah I
mean it'd be impossible my track club
meets on the Lower East Side and we're
all we're competing for space on one
little
lousy little track with all of the
Walkers and you know whatever if every
car in the road was self-driving we
would get on the the FDR Drive and do
our workouts at rush hour on the FDR
Drive and every car would stop yeah and
wait until we were finished right so
it's like I found this idea so fantastic
it's like amazing it makes it means the
really really really cool thing is that
it means and the good thing is it means
you you'll be able to ride your bicycle
through any American City without fear
and that means you will always ride your
bicycle right the only thing that's
preventing us from riding our bicycles
everywhere is that we're legitimately
scared of getting hit and killed now
I've removed that possibility okay so
right so just just to be clear okay
um you know when as they say uh when the
invented American football and people
were cracking their heads open this is a
joke from Jerry Seinfeld right people
are not a joke it's a comedic
observation of reality cracking a head
zone so rather than say maybe we
shouldn't play this sport they said
let's still play the sport but now wear
a helmet okay so so maybe you just have
to add extra rules that constrain
pedestrians so that the traffic can
continue and that's that's a solvable
problem right yeah it's I thought you're
gonna say I thought you were going to
say what you guys said before right
which is maybe the response is you
program the AI into being
crazy just a little bit crazy so you
don't know that could be the one that
doesn't stop at the red light yes yes 95
certainly they're not gonna hit you
right but that the minute is five
percent right then you're like
everybody's thinking now everybody's
reconsidering right let me ask you
something I don't have an answer to and
I thought deeply about it and you're
exactly the kind of guy to think about
it and write about it so right now we
lose at least 30 000 people a year to
traffic deaths that includes pedestrians
I think 35 000 a year so that's 100 a
day and it's been that way for decades
okay you introduce self-driving cars and
that number drops to near zero but
initially it won't be near zero it might
be thousands okay of deaths and these
are deaths from errors in the software
or the the the the the the pattern
recognition software thinks it's a clear
road but there's a truck in the way
that's actually happened it has actually
happened so how do you convince people
that two thousand deaths are better than
thirty five thousand deaths if those two
thousand deaths are from the errors of a
machine built by somebody in Detroit
uh it's you're right it requires some
persuasion but I don't think it's
framed properly I don't think it's a
difficult proposition for people I mean
I am a hundred percent in favor of the
autonomous driving Revolution even as I
recognize it creates a strain a an
interesting world where you can't
actually drive a car in a city anymore
which I'm fine with get rid of them as
far as I'm concerned
um but I do and also I think the
transition
you said eventually we'll get to zero I
think we'll get to zero really quickly
because I think these AI systems okay
learn really quickly they're fast you
know what it's essentially gone to zero
are airplane deaths it's essentially
zero they're essentially zero yes and if
you I was talking to the the engineers
at Google
um who who have created waymo and if you
will tell if you ask them they'll say
you know just in the last two years
two years waymo has gotten uh
like so better that the experience of
driving of sitting in the back of a of
of a waymo in in um Arizona is you can
perceive the difference between now and
two years ago oh wow okay the car is
just driving a lot more the AI is
driving it a lot more smoothly it's it's
there are fewer situations where it
seems to be confused it
um I was stunned driving in the back of
this way mode it it it's amazing I mean
it's and I think that's the other thing
that once people experience the what it
feels like to be in these vehicles what
you quickly realize is how much better
it is than you are and you're much less
likely I think to be concerned about the
occasional mistake plus they don't
consume ethanol
um right yeah yeah right exactly but the
other thing in your in your in your high
ball drink yes the other thing is the
insurance companies are such uh benefit
from this so much that what they'll be
able to do is put together and make a
fund where you pay people a lot more if
they are harmed either either in an
accident or if they're killed wait wait
we'll run you down like there was the
the initial accident that happened
remember there was a fatality involving
an autonomous vehicle yes in in Arizona
in Phoenix I think two or three years
ago and it was because a woman crossed
was jaywalking and she had a bicycle
right and what happened is the
autonomous vehicle approached and the AI
had a category for bicycle and a
category for jaywalker for human
jaywalker but no category for human and
bicycle and it was confused he'd never
seen this before and it didn't know what
to do and it was going back and forth
between is it a bicycle is it a human is
it a bicycle is a human and while it was
undergoing this this so that's AI
artificial idiocy because any human
would know that difference okay yeah it
hits the woman now the point is that
only happens once right that if your
system is
set up properly the next time you have a
category for that and that's what the
building codes it's like building codes
every code in there is because something
happened uh that where people died for
for construction and fire
um so so Malcolm now I'm wondering why
there's a warning that not put my cat in
the microwave
somebody did it
all right so so I agree so this would
rapidly Converge on something being
completely safe so what about the case
you know they're these trolley Quest
problems right in in in sort of moral
philosophy so if if if it goes left it
kills one person if it goes right it
kills two people but it will have to
kill somebody so it goes left and kills
one person is this the kind of the
decisions it's going to have to make or
or is it gonna be so good it never has
to have a trolley problem
well the it's interesting the trolley
problem
um assumes out the possibility the
trolley can just stop
all right so the third the third
strategy is you avoid having to make the
decision at all by sacrificing the
efficiency of the journey and what I
think AI these These are called in in AI
parliaments in autonomous driving
problems these are called Corner cases a
corner case is this difficult tricky to
decipher kind of case and my
understanding is that in most of these
Corner cases what the car does is it
just stops
it's always safer to just stop right it
will always take the it will it will do
what we're reluctant to do as human
drivers which is to compromise the
efficiency of the journey the the AI
will always do that that's one of its
great advantages by the way it's never
in a hurry right right right somebody
should I would imagine that if somebody
figured out what percentage of fatal
accidents happen because someone is in a
hurry it would be an enormous number
they changed the warnings on on signs
they say traffic and you know 20-minute
delay plan for being late
because once you plan for it then you
don't have to rush anymore because now
everyone expects you to be late I mean
it's a psychological uh dimension of the
of the in the The Helpful sign
information on the freeways yeah but so
let me ask you Malcolm humans are
programming these Ai and then they sort
of continue to program themselves
perhaps so what about the
uh the possibility of bias introduced
and let me just give a fast example you
you surely read the news articles uh in
the last year or so where they had
racist sinks at airports okay but
because
so you go to the sink and I always
wondered I put my hand there and I said
I guess it doesn't work and then a white
person comes behind me and then the
water dispenses once they put their hand
on me so it's checking the reflectivity
of the skin if I have dark skin the
signal does not get back to the center
it's absorbed so it thinks nobody's
there right so I always thought it was
just sorry black man that's right you're
gonna have to have dirty hands dirty
hands so so this so this made the news
all right so I'm just wondering if I'm a
black man crossing the street at night
is the AI gonna know I'm there or is it
going to think clear Street ahead keep
going and okay now let me know
here's the copy got to that Neil are you
Malcolm Gladwell black all right Neil
degrass Tyson black oh your Miles Davis
because guess what one of y'all is dying
you know this is real I always tell my
girlfriend who is a lot darker than I am
black I was like I always tell you if
you you're at it she's out at night in
Manhattan like I was like you can't wear
black I'm sorry you cannot wear black
don't are you nuts like wear a bright
color for God's sake
and she just looks at me like I'm a
Madman but I I you know anyone who's
driven at night knows when when if
someone no this is not just black people
but when some a person dressed all in
black crosses a street that's badly lit
at night it's a problem it's a problem
right correct where why do people I my
fellow Runners we would run it in at
night in you know On a Winter's Night
and uh on us on the streets and they
would be wearing all black outfits I'm
like you you're crazy what are you doing
where are you I always wear a yellow
jacket for a reason I don't want to get
killed by some car I can't see me right
right so these are humans making that
mistake but when your machine makes the
mistake or you don't know to put in as a
programmer to put in some or if you
tested only on white people and think
that it's good for All Humans then this
is a this is a bias even if the person
themselves are if they themselves are
not racist or or in any way they have it
was sort of an unintended consequences
of only thinking that white people are
who's uh you know what you know it's a
great example of this Neil I was
listening to something on these AI
systems and they were developing an AI
system to to um diagnose um uh Derma uh
um for dermatologists to um diagnose uh
to figure out whether something on your
skin was cancerous or not and they went
to all this work and they thought it
worked really well and then they
realized that what the AI was doing was
looking for the presence of a ruler
because in all of the images it was
using to learn from they were textbook
images where there was a little ruler
next to the spot
if there's a ruler it's cancerous
clearly oh my goodness but like but no
but that I do think that's a transition
problem right that's the thing about I
totally it is 100 true that AI systems
when you're starting out reflect the
biases okay we gotta kill a few black
people first and then then we're on cue
I guess but you don't but you know over
time I think it's reasonable to assume
but anyway here I am on a podcast with
Neil Tyson and I'm the one defending
science
what is going on here
what I I'm like guys no scientists know
what we're doing no you know what it is
these guys are crazy I can't wash my
hands in the airport if I spend too much
time around Chuck I become angry black
man it is true it is true I will do that
to you you have this this is this is
yeah it's nuts so I just I want to end I
want to we gotta again Land This Plane
could you retell the story that I first
heard you tell us on stage
um what happened when you first started
wearing the afro okay yeah yeah yeah
throw your hair out and you got that
sort of Art Garfunkel kind of Afro there
tell me just could you please retell
that story
well it's I mean I always feel sheepish
telling the story because
um but you're in a safe space here go on
I'm gonna say so I my hair used to be my
hair reflects the fashion of the times
so whenever a black person is wearing
their hair real short I was wearing my
hair real short and then there was a
moment you know where everyone started
to grow their hair long again so my hair
can grow can be quite considerable so
when I in the kind of about 15 years ago
or so I grew my
hair out a lot and discovered of course
that I was getting stopped left and
right by cops on the most trumped up of
like the most absurd you know no I
wasn't even I wasn't even speeding at
the time and I'm sorry sir I'm gonna
have to ask you to step out of the car
sir I'm in the back of a cab
excuse me officer but you got you're
talking to the wrong guy after on a
Sunday morning that's the it's in the
rule book yeah and then and also at
um after 9 11 in um airport security
lines I was getting pulled out and I
realized that that part of the informal
algorithm used by cops and security
officers was
you know big afro codes for something
questionable right this is just a I was
just I don't think it was a kind of
active malignant racism it was just like
actually it's really late it's laziness
there are certain things that trigger so
you're a cop and someone goes past you
at 55 miles an hour okay maybe I must go
a little bit faster but um and you know
you're not getting it's not like you're
focused on the individual you're picking
up a few key things is the person
driving a sports car are they is the car
shiny and New or Old and ratty in my
case they see me drive by and they see a
big afro and they're like all right
let's go get that dude I think that's
what was going on but it was just like I
didn't the last time I had a big afro
was before I had my driver's license so
I'd never been through this very
American rite of passage which is if you
resemble something even remotely black
you get pulled over a lot so I just was
introduced to driving while black you
know my first welcome to the club okay
welcome to the club I was like
is that well I uh I have always been
able to alleviate that problem
personally because I drive with the
driver's capital and all the time oh
there you go
so you lifetime somebody's chauffeur
You're Driving Miss Daisy that's who you
are
that is uh that is a quite a defense
that's good yeah I gotta I need one of
those hats on my dashboard it's like
that's like a throwback it's a throwback
defense right yeah take it back to the
day you're like a porter in the airport
yeah guys we gotta we got a call of
course there Malcolm it's always a
delight to chat with you you're such we
love your perspectives on the world and
and your capacity to share those
perspectives is unmatched uh in all of
your media now with podcasts and books
even books with long titles it's not
subtitles
um Good Luck on on that book thanks for
bringing that story to the front I think
the world needs it and anyone thinking
of the future of War needs it uh so um
Chuck always good to have you as always
a pleasure so Malcolm I want to put if
it's possible you know how some people
have a standing
um uh a table at a restaurant you know
once a month I want a standing
invitation with you for every next
project you do you come on the show I
would love that thank you this is so
much fun in that case we'll be seeing
you once a week
jeez be careful what you wish
I
know
all right we're gonna call it quits
there this has been Star Talk the
Malcolm Gladwell edition of StarTalk
Neil deGrasse Tyson here your personal
astrophysicists
foreign
[Music]